my guest this week is an author the
founding publisher of skeptic magazine a
regular contributor to time.com a
presidential fellow at Chapman
University and now a two-time guest on
the Rubin report Michael Shermer welcome
back returning champions turning how
many weeks in a row D that's right I
could do one more week if I can make it
well I'm thrilled that you're back here
you also are the only guest to have two
books two books
okay all right before it's that very
impressive and the moral are it boosted
my sales right here we'll put the link
down below it's encouraging to see
physical books I mean I'm with a few
people left I think that still likes
physical newspapers physical books you
know I think I don't think I'll ever go
to zero I don't think it'll all ever be
all electronic publishing yeah well it
would be too easy to burn them yeah
that's right yeah it would require less
work I suppose yeah all right so there's
a lot that I want to talk to you about
and I want to be clear with the audience
that right now when we're taping this
it's before the election but we're going
to air this after the election right so
I don't want to do too much politics but
I want to do one thing related to
politics which is very much in your
wheelhouse related to morality and
ethics which is for what you saw for the
purposes of the election do morality and
ethics have anything to do with our
political process anymore
well they it it should have absolutely
everything to do with it of course I
mean in terms of like the moral arc and
expanding the moral sphere and so forth
we know that democracies are much better
than autocracies and Anna Chrissie's and
dictatorships and so on and so what is
it about that that does it well it's
it's the focus on individual liberty and
freedom and the autonomy of individuals
to have choice in the political process
so to that extent the more that there's
money and corruption and the kinds of
things we see not just this election but
really all elections is troubling
because you know any time there's an
interference with individual
participation in the political process
given that we can't have the tyranny of
the majority where we have a
rule we have to have a Bill of Rights we
have to have checks and balances and we
have a constitutional or public that's
good but still you know the kinds of
things we've seen you know in both
candidates both part you know we have a
duopoly you know as libertarians
complain you know this is a two part you
know it's like having only two companies
it's almost like a monopoly because
they're not that far apart right where's
the competition you know my wife some
Germany and you know they have four or
five you know viable active parties that
are up there on the stage and you know
Angela Merkel has always constantly
having to make adjustments and you know
bring these people in and make
accommodations for that party and you
know if we had something like that
Bernie would he be right in there and
the and and Gary Johnson would be right
in there and everybody and so it would
feel like we all have a little bit more
control in power right I mean that to me
would have been the most sensible again
we don't know who the president is right
a second we don't know who won the
election but that would have been the
most sensible thing even to see both
these parties split in two so that the
the Republican Party could have split
into something more you know you would
add Trump and then I think even better
than Gary Johnson would have been a Rand
Paul someone really more traditionally
libertarian or even flip that ticket
with well there's the or weld I think
would have been better but when then on
the left you have you have the Hillary
party that's sort of the more mainstream
Democrats and the progressive breeze
right which is Bernie but what do you
think about just sort of the ethics of
morality related to truth in all of this
because I think that more than anything
over the course of the last year we've
seen truth like an empirical truth go
out the window it doesn't matter what
they say because they're their team's
back them and then even when you when
people tell you they're fact-checking
you know we've got the live back judges
and I'm always looking at them going
well who's back you disappear yes it's
troubling it is so I you know I always
turn to the fact checkers to like okay
what's the week yeah and and you're
right who's checking the fact checkers
and the one who's watching the Watchers
and well that's why we need a free press
and and more you know a different
alternative media in hopes that it
doesn't seem to matter though you know
to the candidates once they're there the
main parties selected person that's it
you know
rallies around the team because of the
duopoly think it's like that's our team
gonna back them no matter what yeah what
about the truth right yeah and and you
know to that extent of course as you
know Sam and I agree Sam Harrison I
agree that you know there are real
factual moral principles I mean they
they're no different than say biological
facts for things we can discover about
nature and to that extent you know the
long-term moral progress comes from us
discovering what those are you know
through social science through democracy
votes just asking people you know what
is it you want and and you know it's a
form of data collection that we get to
know that and and the political process
is still sort of old-school like these
are these are the planks at our platform
and I'm sticking to unmanned or what
yeah but what if what if this one in
this one are not correct
so what troubles me most is the you know
this I'm this is my team I'm sticking to
it no matter what but once in a while
I'd like to hear a candidate say you
know what I changed my mind about guns
or I change my mind about drugs you know
I've looked at it and I just changed my
mind yeah it would be so refreshing
isn't it funny that we we hate when
people flip-flop and yet at the same
time we want people to have flexible
Minds I mean I don't mind changing my
opinions as new information is given to
me but the second a politician does and
maybe that's just because of function of
our system and money so you never know
which why they're flip-flopping right
but we should want people to actually
change their minds right well yes as
rational critical thinkers we do but the
problem with with the political system
it's based on these moral foundations
that you know that kind of the
principles of our team this is what we
stand for and so the more you vary from
that you can vary a little bit and still
be accepted into the team but if you go
too far then maybe we can't trust you on
these other things like okay wait wait
you've changed your mind on guns well if
you're giving up on guns you know what
about capitalism what about Liberty what
about oh my gosh you know you're gonna
go over to the crazy left and vice versa
so instead of it being treated more like
you know sort of a science like I just
want to know what the truth is what's
the best way to reduce the amount of gun
carnage for example should we have you
know this amount of gun control or this
amount or this immuno
but instead it's it's more of a moral
foundation is freedom to choose any and
you can have any guns you want and so on
if you interfere with that even a little
bit no matter what the data says then
you've sacrificed it so we're really at
two different levels factual truth and
and a moral commitment to a principle
right so without making this about guns
specifically so you're saying basically
certain people are just staking out
almost a fake moral yes but basically
and then they derive all of their other
decisions are based on this fake moral
positioning so then they can reject you
on almost anything else well the city so
use climate change you know it's like
people don't know much about it at all
but they you know they they know they're
supposed to if you're on the right
you're supposed to be against it because
somehow it's it's against capitalism
yeah and and so whether you're measuring
you know ice core data or tree-ring data
it's like whatever I don't know I'm
against it because it's challenging my
moral principles about capitalism and
free markets so really has nothing to do
with climate at all right it's it is a
fake it is a fake posturing I'm really
sick it's a signaling theory costly
signaling theory I'm signaling to my
team you can count on me I don't care
what the data is I'm against that so
that's interesting so right behind me
right here I have a book by Alex Epstein
the moral case for fossil fuels and I
don't know that I ever got more of a
push back ever on any show that I've
done then when I had him on most of the
people were saying well you know he's
denying climate change which I don't
think he specifically does you argues
with some of the signs around it but
just by just titling it that the moral
case yeah yes you've got the moral how
would you
in general deal with someone that if you
don't believe their thesis to start with
yes how would you go about having the
conversation because I wanted to I
genuinely wanted to hear his ideas yes I
knew that certain amount of people read
this book and really liked it some
people that I respect and I read it and
I thought I want to hear these ideas but
in saying I don't want to shout him down
every time he says alright I might write
well you're about as good as he is it is
it gets on doing that without beat you
know you
you don't want to be too confrontational
because the moment you'd say you know
well your position is it's a bunch of
[ __ ] then you're wrong
you know the wall goes up cognitive
dissonance kicks in you double down on
your position you're not even listening
to the other arguments you really need
to show I'm listening to you I really
just genuinely want to know what is your
argue this with like the Holocaust
deniers what what what is it you
claiming here just tell me what's your
best arguments for the creationists
what's your best arguments and they'll
usually tell you if they feel like
you're listening you don't have to agree
you can just say I'm not sure I agree
you know and or you might say like I
have with case of the creations because
I used to be one well you know I used to
you know when I was a Christian I used
to believe the creation of stuff you
know and you did yeah yeah yeah yeah so
tell me what's that what are the new
arguments and they want to know well how
come you don't believe that anymore
like could this happen to me and you
know saying you show that it's easier to
get somebody to change their mind if if
you were in their seat once they feel
like you sure you're showing me respect
you're listening to me so I will listen
to you then you know it's a kind of a
quid pro quo it's a perspective taking
and by the way I know that you actually
put this into practice because you
tweeted something really beautiful you
were speaking what just a couple weeks
ago and someone asked you what was the
exact question I don't want to muck it
up and then I tweeted your response
about why wouldn't I cheat on my wife oh
yes yes yes yes yes right well so yeah I
was debating a Christian apologist at
Biola the Bible Institute of LA so it's
you know summer I'm in a room full of
born-again Christian boy and so you know
this is so the guy I just don't get it
why you know what if there's no God
what's the foundation for morals where
is the external source of of absolute
morality and so you married and yeah
yeah is your wife here no well so
tonight's your big night you know look
let's say I talk you into you know
there's no God you get convinced by me
maybe would you cheat on your wife and
he said well I might Oh glad your wife's
not here near that but but why I mean
he's well why wouldn't I I mean
according to you were just you know
electric meat we're Stardust you know a
thousand years we're all dead doesn't
matter anyway so why not yeah you know I
say well how about
could you love your wife and you
promised her you wouldn't and you
wouldn't want her doing that to you and
you don't want to hurt her and you
wouldn't want to live in a society where
everybody just cheats on one another no
one honors their principles contracts or
work and he was like oh and and I don't
think that you know he didn't really
understand that or didn't know that he
had to know that at some level right and
and of course if his wife was there she
goes yeah you idiot but I think this is
nothing new with God but but I think
because he's in this in the bubble in
that team I mean that moral group of you
know this is what we believe there has
to be an external source for morality
God is that external source I'm and I'm
just not gonna think about it much
beyond that yeah so when you give them a
few arguments it's like oh yeah yeah
yeah of course yeah yeah then it's just
obvious once you say it do you think it
matters if someone gets their morality
from an external source if their
morality is good if even if it's based
on something that's unprovable in the
short-term no I don't care as long as
they're not flying planes into buildings
or bothering me or you know killing me
or whatever I don't care
to that extent you know certain
religions that lead people to say you
know man the soup kitchens you know give
money to Hurricane Katrina disaster
relief that kind of stuff that's great
good ok fine you have that you know
makes the world a little bit better
place that's good in the long run it's
probably better if if the reason you do
it is is inherently in itself rather
than for some reward system in the
afterlife or because you know God is
watching or something like that to me it
and in internally motivated moral system
as a superior one I'm doing it just
because it's the right thing to do yeah
and usually at this point Hitler comes
into the conversation yeah but then that
you know so yeah but okay for it
forget Hitler you know that that we you
know we've made progress well you're not
arguing that that people can't do bad
things based on their own decisions of
course they do they do they do do that
yes right yeah all right so then that's
a perfect segue to free will which I
want to really get into it all right
because I Sam Harris
you know launched my my first version of
the show last year relaunch with him the
second time
a couple months ago yeah and we went
into freewill and I reread the barely a
book it's uh well we call that it's a
small like it's a booklet all right it's
a booklet and the entire I told him this
when he was sitting right there I said
you know the whole time I was reading it
I really wanted to disagree with him
because by his argument about know that
you don't have free will it made me feel
sort of powerless as a person hmm and
then he laid out his case of why we
don't have free will you don't quite
agree with that but would would the best
way to be to start here with you may be
summing up his his version of it well
for ya I mean generally that the
positions you could take is you could be
a libertarian in the in the free well
sense that and and that's the smallest
cohort of people who study this that is
that somehow we have some
decision-making machinery in our brain
or a soul or something like that almost
nobody accepts that then there's the
determinist position which is about the
same size as those libertarians then the
largest cohort about sixty percent for
people they don't know the determinant
the determinant so this would be Sam's
position and he is today probably the
most articulate defender of that
position in his book his interviews with
you and other things he's done he lays
it out as clearly as anybody probably
ever has right so if you're determinist
this is your man he's gonna make the
best arguments that is everything we do
is is determined by previous causal
vectors so there's a causal net to the
universe we live in a determined
universe our genes our upbringing our
peer groups all the things we have no
control over have shaped our neurons and
our genes to be a certain way and these
things just bubble up and in our in our
brain so you know thoughts pop in
behaviors happen over which we have well
no control if your determinist so so
quite literally what he would say is
that every the cosmic stew and all of
your experiences that brought us right
this very moment to this place that i
actually would not choose to either
throw this glass of water at you or not
right because i would only do it if
right the choice had actually been made
along the roadmap right in front of me
that that basically that's right i think
on this show Sam used the argument that
most of us disk
is the Charles Whitman in the University
of Texas belltower shoots people left a
note at his apartment after before he
did this if something's wrong with me I
just know there's something wrong with
my brain after I'm dead
you know autopsy so they did and you
know that sure enough there's a tumor in
his brain okay and and there's other
cases like I write about in the moral
arc the other famous case of the the
pedophile the 44 year old man who
suddenly as pedophilic thoughts and then
actions about his stepdaughter so the
the wife's you know puts a kibosh on
that turns him into social services he's
in big trouble and then they discover
he's got a brain tumor near the
hypothalamus that affects this they take
the brain tumor out and he no longer has
pedophilic feelings at all the the
kiddie porn on the computer had gone and
and he's back to normal and then all of
a sudden you know the wife catches him
again with the kiddie porn and stuff
scan his brain the tumors back okay so
Sam's argument is that it's all tumors
now we would say oh but he has a tumor
he's not really a pedophile or Charles
Whitman wasn't really a homicidal maniac
killer he had a brain tumor
the determinist position is you and I
have backgrounds that are like tumors we
just can't see it in a brain scan but
all the neural networks that are laid
out that cause you to throw the glass or
not or shoot the person or not it is
just the same it's just there
yeah and that I he lays out a good case
for it I'm not absolutely and I'm there
like I'm sort of there and now we'll get
to your rationalizations well okay so
what is the difference between these if
I throw a glass of water you while we're
doing this we're gonna and then I might
throw the glass back on the normally
would yes yeah so but what is the
difference between say a brain tumor and
and you and I just sitting here without
brain tumors and it has to do with what
they and Anna calls degrees of freedom
that is to what extent do you have
control over your behavior and instead
of seeing it as just a black and white
ooh categories you're either free or
you're totally determined or totally
free Dan lays out a case that it's a
spectrum so insects say have very few
degrees of freedom its
instincts they have very simple they
don't really have brains it's these
little neural nodules and say you know
rodents have more degrees of freedom
than insects but fewer the dogs dogs
more than rodents chimpanzees more than
dogs us more than chimps and within the
human spectrum you have the brain tumor
the you know the Charles Whitman's on
the one end and you know say you and I
are just regular people without tumors
or whatever and you have drug addicts
and you know and alcoholics and you know
people that have certain conditions that
give them fewer degrees of freedom now
it's not freedom in the libertarian
sense but it's you know you're going
along the pathway the insect can only
ever do this you know the dog can do
these two and we can do all five now
what's doing the choosing well you are
well Sam would say yeah but there is no
you it's just neurons firing well okay
so Benjamin lab a famous experiment
where you know the this the the
scientists can tell which one you're
going to choose before you even know
because these motor neurons are firing
subconsciously and we can read that on a
brain scan so yeah but you can override
it free won't and that's a different
part of your brain in any case it's all
your brain so it's bubbling up from you
you're overriding your cortex or
prefrontal cortex is overriding the
impulses bubbling up from it and then
some other part is choosing to override
the override er it's all still you
making the decision more than say the
dog could and and it's a little bit of a
linguistic game right so that that's
where I almost Lee were yeah what do you
mean by choose okay these words you know
volition choice freedom it becomes
problematic and I think this is why it's
an it's an insoluble problem because of
language and just how we talk about all
scientists say we live in a determined
universe that's a given
okay well then how could there be
freedom well okay so let me return I
thought about this here's an example so
Sam is married I know his wife they have
a great marriage and he's a super moral
guide the chance of him cheating on his
wife are very very low
but they're not zero because he's a
human even though God's not watching but
but they're not zero because he's a
human so let's say it happens you know
he's at a conference whatever you just
something happens and you know and he
gets caught and his wife confronts him
and he says well honey see it's tumors
all the way down you know my neurons
like my genes my eye you know I had this
long pathway that led me to you know I
didn't make that choice it just happened
you know how could he even finish the
sentence before you know before she
slapped him upside that right Ennis in a
practical sense it's a useful fiction of
that we do feel like we're making
choices and you really could have done
different maybe the brain tumor guy
can't do different because he has little
control over his brain but without the
brain tumors and there really is a
difference it's not tumors all the way
down there's a difference between
certain networks of choice that are in
there where you really could have done
different you know and you know that's
the best analogy I can come up with so a
lot of people asked when I talked to Sam
about it they said you know some people
said I agree with them some disagree but
a lot of people said why does it matter
that that seems to be the the biggest
take away of everything why does it
matter which I understand it some of its
like we're talking this out but at the
end of the day whether it's all the
primordial stew and every event that
I've had that leads me to not have the
free will or whether it all leads me to
have it why does it actually matter well
I think it does matter for the legal
system for example in Germany again
where my wife's from they have a
criminal justice system that's more
focused on rehabilitation and restore
what's called restorative justice versus
retributive justice now America is sort
of steeped in this judeo-christian moral
system in which you punish the sinner
and the transgressor they must get their
just desserts it's very old testament
yeah and you know for all the Christian
talk on the right you know they're not
very forgiving when it comes to that
sort of thing you know deal you know fry
them and old Sparky you know at the
electric chair you know given what are
we still doing the electric here they're
in somewhere I don't think anyone's
doing the electric chair anymore
the problem was you know people's heads
caught on fire and it was upsetting to
the people watching and so on there's
only four states that it's legal in 31
States there's only four that really
practice at Texas Oklahoma Ohio and
Florida and and even there except for
Texas they've executed 514 people since
1982 so they're pretty active but state
of California we have an execute anybody
since I think the 90s and you know most
of them die of old age so it's really
kind of a barbaric practice so the and
the reason is is because we've come to
understand that in a utilitarian sense
if we want to improve society the old
country-western song you know just hang
them all and let God sort it out is not
the best way to make a better society
and and in part is because a better
understanding of the brain so this would
be an argument for determinism in a way
in Germany they most of the criminals
live in these apartment like cells you
know the doors they can go in and out
they're not locked you know they have a
lot of freedom and the whole point is
the give them classes and education and
you got to get them out of here and back
into society working yeah and it works
pretty well I mean not for the super
crazies the extremes this you know the
Psychopaths and you know even Sam would
agree you know yeah don't let those
crazy Psychopaths and the pedophiles out
don't let them out you know we're not
there yet to rehabilitate them but but
America admired in that Old Testament
you know don't let any of them out just
hang them all yeah and so we're pretty
slow on that so that there are
consequences to that yeah is that one of
the big flaws I guess of the Old
Testament that morality is sort of
really detached from it you know we're
based in judeo-christian laws here right
I don't think most people are walking
around thinking that the actual laws
that they live under are based in
religion but there is a religious
component but you're given a great
example of why that has very little to
do with something that is actually moral
yes well and the criminal justice system
doesn't well this part of the problem
with the restorative justice movement
the points they make is that the victim
isn't restored
you know when the state try somebody
they don't give any money to the victims
or they don't restore the damage that
stolen car or the person that dot you
know what you know I guess you could sue
for punitive
that's civil courts you've got to go to
civil court the goldmans had to sue oj
and civil court get the damages even if
they had found oj guilty and he spent
the rest of his life in jail
that doesn't help the Goldmans so that's
an actually really interesting point so
just to be clear he he got off free they
said he was innocent there there was
enough evidence right but he lost the
civil case yes because it has a lower
threshold yes so they were able to get
money and everyone knew oj did it well
if you could collect collect but in
effect in theory right they got money or
whatever they got I don't even know if
they ever got it actually but it's just
an interesting thing that we have these
two sort of course different levels of
the burden of proof is different right
thus creating a strange so part of the
restorative justice movement is that
they actually try to introduce the
victim and the in the and the
perpetrators and get them in a room like
this and they talk and you know most of
these these young men they have no idea
yo I just robbed the house whatever yeah
and I do it every night
it's like partying and they have no idea
the damages they do to people
psychologically and so they learn by
talking to the B yeah you ruined my life
dude I mean it's just so upsetting but I
was I couldn't work for months and Wow
really I mean I do I couldn't imagine it
would did wouldn't bother me yeah well
you're a psychopath
so you try to train these people
Adrienne Rayne has a good book that I'd
talk about in the moral arc his book is
called the anatomy of violence he's a
psychiatrist he's he's one of the first
to scan the brains of psychopaths and
serial killers and showed that their
prefrontal cortex is pretty much shut
down so they have all these impulses
bubbling up and no brake on them and so
they they just impulsively act out most
of their violence is done that way and
so his idea was this isn't going to
happen in the next century or so but
ultimately you could somehow fix the
brains genetic engineering brain
chemistry whatever drugs something like
that and that would be the ultimate
rehabilitation right so you could get
them back into society do you think
there would be a moral risk with
something like that if we could
ultimately end we'd almost be
engineering even though it's a flaw I
suppose in our brain but that we'd
alternately be engineering out something
that is very human well I would have to
be done selectively obviously you don't
want to remove the person but like one
of the complaints about some of these
drugs is that they
dampen all emotions and a person just
has a flat effect for like ADHD and some
of these drugs that people take yes
there's always the risk of side effects
but if the choice is he's either we let
him out and he's a killer or a rapist or
we keep him in at a hundred thousand
dollars a year to the state you know
those are neither one of those good
options so let's try something we're not
there yet for that for those serious
ones but something like chemical
castration for pedophiles it doesn't
appear to work that great but that's the
idea somehow fix it so that the impulses
are not there anymore
right and train them to put it you know
to have some self-control so one of the
points Pinker makes in his great book
the better angels of our nature is that
we and he's citing Norbit aliases book
the civilizing process is that over the
course of about five hundred years
Europeans learn to control their
impulses just like at books of etiquette
and self-control like what you shouldn't
shouldn't do at a party and when you
meet people and you stay a toe at a
hotel things you don't urinate in the
corner and you know don't don't pick the
meat at the table with your fingers and
just basic stuff that we take for
granted is second nature
people have to be taught that yeah and
so one of the expansions of the moral
sphere is just to is to learn to control
our impulses and and we can learn that
so back to the free will you know you
can learn to control your willpower you
can learn you can read those books on
willpower like Roy Baumeister book
willpower here's the things you can do
to train your brain when you have those
impulses like don't don't go shopping on
an empty stomach because you're gonna
buy ice cream and cookies and stuff you
shouldn't eat right you know and when
you fill out the breakfast card at the
hotel you know do it the night beat you
know night before when you're full so
you put the granola instead of the bacon
and eggs right the next morning but
there's a hundred things like that you
could do the Train but but your here's
back to the freeway year ago freely
choosing to control your own impulses
that's still you doing it and and you
could you can do otherwise right and
that's where it really comes down to
semantics though because Sam's argument
would go back to well you're controlling
it but you're only controlling it within
the subset that you're yes humanik
importance right
so so just one final so there was a big
survey done in 2013 of 3,300
professional philosophers professors and
graduate students so these are all
either PhD philosophers or getting their
PhDs and they asked them like 50
different their positions on 50
different big issues in philosophy one
of which is free will so 59 percent were
compatible Asst which is my positioned
and Anna's position maybe Sam's may be
against the words you know that we live
in a determined universe you don't have
libertarian free will but in some way
you are making choices you it's maybe
it's a useful fiction but it's a very
good useful fiction because we have to
live in the world and and you do free
you feel like you're making choices only
12 percent and 13 percent were
libertarians and hardcore determinists
then the rest were other whatever that
is yeah so either that 59% are just not
thinking it through clearly enough to
see that the determinant is a correct
one or it's not a soluble problem it's
just that yeah because of the language
and how could the universe be determined
and we make freedom right that that's
sort of where I see this yeah for
whatever splitting hairs that we're at
right between you and Sam oh now that's
kind of where I say you know something
that you said about just our controlling
our impulses in something it's almost as
if the more we control our impulses I
don't mean our impulses to kill or do
really horrible things but sort of basic
impulses I was thinking of Downton Abbey
did you watch Downton Abbey by any
chance so you know they had the the rich
yeah you know landowners and and all the
people that were rich and wealthy and
had everything upstairs and they had all
the people the servants downstairs and
after watching the entire series it
became obvious to me that the people
downstairs who had much less where to
live sometimes eating scraps or or
struggling for life in a lot of ways
were much happier than the people who
sort of controlled all of their impulses
through society so there's something
connected to happiness there too right
it could be yes I don't I don't know
haven't seen a show so I don't well not
even not difficult but the idea that
sort of controlling your impulses to
sort of fit in a societal thing may not
be yeah well you turn
you can overdo that right yeah
absolutely yeah well happiness okay so
much of it happiness does have to do
with to what extent you have some
control over your life so people in in
dictatorships and totalitarian regimes
have almost no control and their
happiness levels are much lower for
other reasons also poverty and so on but
but we know from other studies
unhappiness that you know people just
having choices the more choices for the
most part makes them feel just happier
just for what you know self satisfied
satisfaction or whatever yeah so there
is a relationship there you know also
having goals and having a you know
meaningful work and relationships and
things like that all contribute to it
money you know there's a certain you
know you get you to a certain level but
not beyond do all of those things do you
think they all have a tipping point I
mean either with choices or with money
it's like you know if you're going to
buy a couch if you only had if you had
20 couches it seems manageable but now
I'm lying you could have you could spend
your life if yes go into these holes
where they spend their life worrying
about this mine user so they're almost
all of these things and money to write
know that yeah there is absolutely is a
tipping point right well so we developed
cognitive strategies one of them is
called satisfice sound of spicing in
which so you're standing there in this
sea of on the wall of toothpastes you
know it you could spend two hours going
through them all and I like the blue one
boom next or the one that I always get
are the couches yes I just bought a
couch you know at night yeah oh it's
like oh my god right so at some point
you just go oh if I get I'm just gonna
do this one I like the blue one or the
grey one or whatever and and so actually
much of life is like that it you could
without emotions like people would
damage to the amygdala and the limbic
systems that flattened their emotions
and it have the hardest time making
choices they're the rational brain still
works they can do the calculations this
one has this many calories this one has
this much fat and this one protein which
bar should I get you know actually
that's not productive they have these
people have a hard time even leaving the
house yeah like what should I do next
and you think about it and think about
it most of our decisions are actually
made on spontaneously emotionally sort
an intuitive instinctive rapid cognition
it's called process so in terms of
making a choice when I go to this
college or that college if it's really
right down to two and you can't tell it
really doesn't matter which one yeah and
that's really the only way that human
society could flourish right like
ultimately it would have to come down to
something that's sort of innate in us
otherwise we would be caught forever in
battling out absolutely endless options
of everything now where it gets
interesting where we started with you
know politics and morality there's
something called libertarian paternalism
I don't know if you're familiar I think
well it's called it so the overarching
thing is called choice architecture so
like for example in your on your
California driver's license you can
punch a tab it says you'll be an organ
donor
you will volunteer to be an organ donor
and so California gets whatever
percentage of people that do that in
Oregon you are going to be a organ donor
unless you punch the tab that says I opt
out so the opt-in versus opt-out Oregon
has a much higher rate of organ donation
and for that very reason so who makes
that decision politicians right the
state Senate or the state constitution
whoever makes that decision so in a way
you know politicians or say well you
still have choice you don't have to give
your organ but we know that if we give
people the chance to opt out versus opt
in it's gonna have a different rate of
participation so what what does that say
about humans right there I mean does
that just say something about our
Western laziness or something because
this is a big choice what you whether
regardless of whether you think you're
going to heaven or you just into dust or
whatever it is that's actually a fairly
big life choice so to speak whether yes
you know use your organs to help other
people or not and just simply by opt in
or opt out forcing them to click opt out
it's gonna get ya higher what does that
say about just laziness
well intellectual laziness but also just
a lack of rational calculation about
these things and most people aren't good
at that
it's like most could well so that this
this principles have been applied to
like corporations and health care
programs or retirement programs for the
employees most employees they don't they
don't even want to sit and read through
the 20 different investment options for
the
401k so usually what the company will do
is say well we're giving you this one
now you don't have to take it you can
take this one over here if you want but
the studies show this one in the long
run will be the bestest when slightly
riskier could pay off more could lose
more you can opt out out of this one and
go for that one if you want most take
this one and so it paternalistically the
CEO and the board have decided well we
think it's best for our employees that
they do this but we don't wanna force
them right so that's the libertarian
paternalism libertarian element yeah
right well I know that's true because
when I mean when we started this company
the production company that you know
handles Rubin report and I was getting
health insurance and the guy sent me
this page of 50 different things right
and I immediately wrote back I wasn't
gonna go through that and I said can you
give me yes and I'm not even sure I
really looked at this right I picked the
best right out of three right and that
was that but that just so it sort of
were we're intellectually lazy but were
we're also maybe that's just a function
of 21st century minds or our patients is
then are well people don't have it well
sit people have the time to go through
all that stuff or they don't even
understand it I mean some of these are
pretty complex these investment tools or
super complex that healthcare programs
are complex so this is the the idea that
certain libertarians don't like too much
but in fact works better is if you have
some committee of experts that sort of
goes through these things and I could
force us to do it you know let our
freedom but they give us the choices and
limit the choices just because it's
what's best so we are in a way making
decisions for what it's sort of the
trolley problem you know what what is
really the best way there's people dying
that need organs where can we get the
participation level is kind of low so
let's just change the choice
architecture you are given and unless
you opt out and other states go well we
don't want that okay fine
so we have 50 experiments running at any
one time on all these different issues
and I think that's this is a way in
which politics and science intersect in
a way those are social experiments you
know this state has income taxes when
there's no income taxes when as
progressive tax flat tax regressive tax
you know you can sort of look at all the
experiments and see the outcomes to
whatever extent it's a little messy
right and then you can say well
I want that one okay you can move there
you can try to change the laws in your
own state then those are all experiments
yeah so you're really making the best
argument for not to bring this back to
politics but you're making the best
argument for states rights really yeah
are you saying these are all incubators
basically and and the hope is that which
ones work will eventually trickle up to
the federal level I tend to prefer
states rights over the federal power
just because there's more choice and in
the end the last chapter the moral arc I
speculated in the long run maybe in a
few centuries nations will fall into
disuse borders will become ever more
porous they already are economically and
more politically and we'll kind of
return to the old city state because you
know people like Stewart Brand from the
long now foundation projects that it's
something like 80 percent of the world's
population will live in cities by 2100
so cities is where the action is it's
where all its economic choices and
freedom and prosperity and and so so
when I just have city states and people
just live wherever they want this would
remove the nation-state too much power
in a nation a single individual you know
we're concerned you know what if Trump
has the power to Hillary has all that
power whoever well I guess the argument
against that would be that the
city-states would eventually have the
same goals as nation-states well yeah
maybe that could happen but but the more
that power is dispersed amongst actors
political actors then the less likely
any one person will get power and so to
return it to Hitler you know there
there's good arguments now to be made
that no Hitler no Holocaust no Hitler in
a World War two I mean he was really the
sole architect that made that happen
even against the wishes of most of his
underlings who thought it I don't know
it's such a good idea this war thing you
know look what happened in World War one
and so on
and yet but so take you but had he not
come to power probably none of that
would have happened that that's too much
power in one individual that's what
scares me about big political units
you